today we stand on the threshold of a new
golden age of space exploration the
first of three missions that will see
humans return to the moon for the first
time in five decades
the sls or space launch system today
rests on the stand waiting to ignite its
engines taking the orion capsule on a
journey around the moon
this is an exciting launch for any true
aerospace enthusiast but legitimate
questions about the sls have been raised
questions about its very existence in an
era of innovation that has allowed the
private space industry to drastically
reduce the cost of launch why is nasa
building its own completely unreusable
rocket why has it cost so much money to
manufacture and why does it exist at all
the sls is a massive rocket building on
not just the legacy of the saturn
program but the space shuttle program
borrowing concepts and actual parts from
each system the sls uses two solid
rocket boosters together they will
produce more than 75 percent of the
rocket's thrust at launch burning five
tons of propellant every six seconds and
providing the equivalent thrust of 14
four-engined 747 jumbo jets
each
these boosters are essentially the same
boosters that flew on the space shuttle
in fact they are using many leftover
parts from the space shuttle program
with some updated designs to the nozzle
and an additional fifth booster segment
giving this new generation booster 25
more fuel capacity over the shuttles
however unlike the solid rocket boosters
of the space shuttle these boosters will
not be recovered and refurbished in an
era where we can literally fly our
boosters back to the ground
this seems like a strange choice
why did nasa decide to go this route
to understand that we have to look back
in time two programs were cancelled in
2011 the space shuttle program and the
constellation program
we are all familiar with the space
shuttle program but the constellation
program is less known due to the fact it
only ever flew a prototype rocket
the aries prototype flew in 2009 and
tested the orion launch abort system if
that name sounds familiar that's because
orion is the same spacecraft that will
be flying on top of the sls
the orion spacecraft was originally
designed for the constellation program
before its cancellation in 2011.
in fact if we look at the final planned
aries rocket design the aries 5 it bears
a striking resemblance to the sls
that's no coincidence just as parts from
the space shuttle program were scavenged
for the sls designs and employees were
taken from the constellation program we
see this pattern play out throughout the
sls design the giant orange insulation
covered core stage containing two
gigantic propellant tanks holding two
million liters of liquid hydrogen and
742 000 liters of liquid oxygen will be
feeding four rs-25 engines
these engines are not only the same
design used in the space shuttle but
they are literally scavenged from
previously flown space shuttles the four
engines for artemis one have these
serial numbers and from that we can
track their flight history these engines
have a rich history within nasa bringing
components of the iss to orbit and
flying astronauts to hubble to repair
and maintain it these are tried and
tested engines that in theory would save
nasa money but oddly the sls program's
greatest criticism is its cost
running up a bill of 23 billion dollars
when barack obama released the us
government's budget in 2010 the
constellation budget showed all zeroes
the program was effectively cancelled
obama's vision for nasa's future was for
collaboration between commercial space
partners like spacex while shifting
nasa's budget and focus to projects
which were not commercially viable a
vision that has largely come to fruition
today
so if the constellation program was
cancelled in 2010 how is this
resurrected frankenstein's monster
standing on the pad today
ready to launch to the moon
the answer
politics
this legislation will define nasa's
future by building on its past obama's
cancellation of the constellation
program was met with criticism from
politicians from all over the united
states
the elevated costs of the program was
partially by design nasa gained support
in congress by spreading jobs all across
the united states
ensuring widespread support by the
constituents of the politicians in each
region when the constellation program
was cancelled it left thousands of
people without work
people were understandably upset
this forced the obama administration to
backpedal resulting in the nasa
authorization act of 2010 being signed
providing nasa budget to both commercial
space launch industry and in effect
brought the constellation program back
from the dead under a new name
artemis
the act even specified that nasa needed
to reuse technology contracts and
workforce from the constellation program
and so here we are 12 years later with
the ghost of constellation flying to the
moon itself a frankenstein's monster of
space shuttle components
this is clearly not an efficient way of
developing a rocket
canceling one over budget project and
then bringing it back a couple of months
later with added design restrictions
that's perfectly obvious to anyone and
everyone involved it's just how
bureaucracy in a democratic system
shakes out sometimes
could that money have been better spent
elsewhere absolutely would it have been
spent to nasa without the intentional
cost and efficiencies probably not
this was a jobs program where we get an
incredible rocket as the output
the sls despite its inefficiencies is
undeniably cool
the sound of solid rocket boosters is
something i have dreamt of experiencing
i don't think anyone with an honest love
of aerospace can look at this machine
and not be in awe it looks like someone
asked mid journey to create a hybrid of
the saturn 5 and space shuttle and
perhaps that's nostalgia for an era i
was born too late to experience but that
era took us to the moon
i have a tattoo of buzz aldrin on the
moon on my leg to say i'm excited is an
understatement
this machine if all goes to plan is
going to take us back to the moon with
the progress happening in the commercial
space industry following hot and nasa's
heels we will have cheaper heavy-lift
rockets capable of taking us to the moon
and further nasa won't need to funnel
money into a project like this again
instead being able to focus on projects
like the james webb telescope this is an
exciting time in aerospace and human
space flight after a lull of more than
50 years
times are changing
this is a stepping stone to a permanent
human habitat on the moon and maybe
someday mars
i grew up watching documentaries about
the moon missions always with a little
bit of sadness that i didn't get to
experience that live broadcast with the
rest of the world documentaries like
hack the moon armstrong and crisis on
apollo 13 felt like watching a marvel
movie
real life superheroes
you can relive that nostalgia and get
excited for this new generation of
heroes and stories by watching these
documentaries on curiosity stream for
14.79 a year an insanely low price
these are just a small collection of the
aerospace and aviation documentaries
available on curiositystream and you
will also get access to my new
aviation history documentary series the
battle of britain on nebula nebula is
our creator-owned streaming platform
that allows us to release work that may
not work on youtube in our newly
released episode we explore the
ground-based anti-aircraft technologies
employed by britain to protect its
cities and strategic resources diving
into the technology and statistics to
discover just how effective this often
debated tactic was you can watch that
along with other originals like wendover
productions new episode of extremities
on wake island a tiny remote island the
center of the pacific just big enough to
fit a military runway that played a
pivotal role in world war ii
you will get access to both nebula and
curiosity stream for just 1479 a year
it's one of the best deals on the
internet right now and it helps support
this channel to keep bringing you the
videos you love